park en plein grand débat car j'étais le
premier ministre c'était vendredi il a
évoqué la possibilité de lier le
versement des aides sociales dont les
allocations chômage ou du rsa au fait
que les bénéficiaires pourraient
participer à des activités d'intérêt
général
la proposition fait tous et notamment au
sein de la majorité en marche
on en débat mais on écoute d'abord le
premier ministre était donc vendredi
est ce que cette solidarité elle peut
s'accompagner de contreparties
d'activité d'activités d'intérêt général
qu'est ce qu'on demande à ceux qui
bénéficient de la solidarité est ce qu
on demande quelque chose et si oui quoi
et pour compléter sur le sujet je vous
propose d'écouter aussi le secrétaire
national du parti communiste fabien
roussel
il intervenait sur ce sujet ce matin sur
sud radio a mené cette idée là
aujourd'hui c'est une véritable
provocation
pourquoi pas poser le problème autrement
c'est-à-dire créer des emplois qui
répondent à des besoins
il y avait avant les contrats aidés il y
avait il ya des besoins dans les
hôpitaux
au lieu de dire on va verser une
allocation on va vous demander de bosser
mais embauchons carole le premier ici
mais le sujet sur le tapis il sait aussi
que c'était une d1 des thèmes dans le
grand débat qui revient enfin on vous
met le sujet sur le tapis c'est quand
même ce pas d'abord rappelé que c'est un
sujet récurrent vraiment la langue qui
ces débats mais oublie 15 ans est-ce
qu'il faut des contrôles la famille
voilà bon
moi je pense que s'il fait ça c'est pas
tout à fait par hasard je pense que l'on
veut aller un peu péchés du côté de
l'électorat de droite sur le fond je
trouve que c'est en réalité comment il
ya il n'est pas choquant dans l'absolu
on se dise bon quelqu'un après tout qui
bénéficient d'une allocation façon un
travail d'intérêt général dans l'absolu
c'est pas c'est pas choquant maintenant
ces mécanismes sont chargés en fait de
réinsérer faut pas oublier c'est de la
réinsertion en principe est donc moi je
préfèrerais beaucoup qu'on parle de
formation professionnelle qu'on pourrait
qu'on pourrait donner aux bénéficiaires
lui par contre partie ses bras pour je
sais bien mais moi je pense que ce qui
est intéressant c'est que c'est vrai que
c'était problème de sarkozy et celui
évoqué donc on donne sur le week end
cela dit faut pas non plus que futile
qu'on les fasse en version qui dit il
parle pas des mécanismes assurantiels il
parle pas du chômage il parle pas de nom
de la solidarité
la suite a été donc c'est le rsa c'est
pas grave non non c'est une formule
solidarité c'est moi l'assurance
l'association l'allocation adulte
handicapé c'est évidemment une mesure de
solidarité
alors ce serait inconcevable un but et
en contrepartie est ce que tu disais ça
pour le chômage qui elle face à la
population
voilà donc déjà tous à partir sur ce n
est pas dans ce cadre là on a on cotise
on a ensuite des allocations donc
chômage retraite maladie on ne va pas en
plus beau c'est parce qu'on touche sur
notre chance maladie après il ya de la
solidarité dans la solidarité
effectivement c'est pas à mon avis la
même chose le rsa que l'assurance
handicap est donc sa formulation est bon
vous trouvez donc sa formation
ouais et général trop mais ce qui est
trop générale ce matin mais je sais pas
trop des world series motel peux pas le
dire voici un titre après vous devenez
très fouillé le simple fait c'est comme
c'est comme rigolo qui reprennent des
programmes de hockey et ski en tout cas
intéressant c'est que ce qu'on voit bien
c'est que personne mais ils ne font rien
c'est ce que gray voiture ne faudra pas
brûler leurs droits acquis jamendo de
france a donc je sais pas si c'est une
gaffe si c'est volontaire je sais pas
très bien pourquoi il a dit je pensais
c'est que je pourrai ce que c'est pour
marquer ce que dira c'est pour plaire à
la droite mais comme la fin ne le ferons
pas ça paiera personnes réservent la
gauche dénis tillinac et pato pour
plaire à la droite peut être qu'il ya
cette arrière-pensée
sûrement mais c'est surtout pour plaire
à une foule nombreuse très nombreuses de
petites gens qui sont autour du smig qui
râble alors qui c'est une partie de
du phénomène des jeunes quand j'entends
dire et tout les jours je l'entends
autour de moi ouais nous on bosse on y
arrive et le voisin qui perçoit le rsa
je ne sais quelle allocation
ils traînent toute la journée c'est
scandaleux il pourra les ronds points
c'est à cela qu'on sait même plus
important sa part dont alexis que le
fait que ce soit la même chose que
voquer parce qu'il sait très bien quand
il dit ça qu'il est temps l'écho
d'ailleurs si on faisait des sondages
précis là-dessus à mon avis il aurait
pas approbation
il ya un écho populaire asselah yann
s'est d'autre part c'est une des mesures
demandées dans le grave comme zé maria
vie c'est une façon de montrer pour lui
qu'il écoute ce qui se passe et en plus
dans des intérieurs c'est fascinant
puisqu'avec seulement c'est une fac les
gens à la campagne il fut temps tous les
jours de 10 à 18 ans nouveau boss les
agriculteurs disent nous on bosse et on
aurait trois mois le gars qui touchent
le rsa il fait deux trois petits trucs
au noir à côté il vit mieux en bosse
entre 4 10 fois moins il ya une
initiative qui avait été prise dans le
haut rhin
oui il ya un an le mémoire c'était 7
heures des modèles et c'était validé
pour lui c'était validé au sous réserve
que ça
je suis ça n'empiète pas sur le jeu
serait intéressant de regarder mais de
savoir quel est le bilan après un an de
bonification haut-rhinois et si ça parle
bien virale gros ça marche pas très bien
voilà des bourreaux des mauvais ce sera
l'occasion d'en reparler d'un point de
vue